[Música]
terminó el tour de francia' 2020
increíble y atípico con un triunfo de
taddei por ser el segundo más joven en
la historia en ganarlo es la primera vez
que un esloveno gana la carrera ciclista
más importante del mundo de hecho
eslovenia realiza un histórico doblete
comprimimos rock glitch segundo de la
general el paseo en parís con poco
público por la pandemia recibió al
esloveno en los campos servicios en el
pelotón iban los diez latinoamericanos
que terminaron la competencia ocho de
ellos colombianos vamos a analizar el
papel de los ciclistas latinos en este
especial así como al flamante de campeón
la decepción del jumbo y otros temas con
nuestros invitados a quien agradezco
mucho su presencia
tatiana rodríguez periodistas del diario
'as' colombia leonel puse y analista en
france24 especializado en ciclismo y
juán pupiales periodista deportivo de
nuestro canal que no tengo aquí a mi
izquierda es que pongas el show con dos
etapas en la 20ª y protagonizó en esta
vigésima etapa una fuga en solitario de
35 kilómetros que no sólo le permitió
alzarse con la tercera también lo
propulsó al podio para dimensionar la
increíble remontada juan
o marcará esta acción la historia del
tour de francia en general e incluso la
historia del deporte para mí sin duda
estamos hablando que está la lnd de no
solamente una gesta de si queremos sino
una gesta en la historia del deporte
estamos hablando del tour de france que
es uno de los eventos deportivos más
exigentes del mundo se lo compara con el
mundial de fútbol y con los juegos
olímpicos a este tour de francia' 2020
llegó un chico de 21 años que nunca
había participado en esta competición
llega se cae se queda cortado pierde un
minuto y medio en los abanicos pierde a
fabio aro un ciclista que lo iba a
acompañar en esta labor pierde a formol
y llega a la penúltima etapa es a
contrarreloj con 57 segundos de
desventaja respecto a una especialista
respecto al líder al todopoderoso primos
roble chino solo le gana el tiempo sino
que prácticamente lo humilla en una
especialidad repitiendo lo que ya había
pasado en los campeonatos nacionales de
eslovenia 21 años tiene este chico que
consigue esta gesta sin duda estamos
hablando de una historia que se va a
hablar a lo largo de muchos años en el
deporte vamos ahora con tatiana
rodríguez
periodista del diario 'as' colombia la
tenemos vía remota tatiana describen al
flamante de campeón como un joven sin
complejos que solo entiende una forma de
ganar que es atacar qué opinas al
respecto
así es hablan buenas noches buenas
noches mi ángel puedan para todos los
televidentes muchas gracias por la
invitación si definitivamente tiene
tiene otra forma de pensar su mente es
diferente y creo que es lo que estamos
viendo toda la mayoría de jóvenes que
están irrumpiendo en el ciclismo en este
momento y que son los que vamos a ver en
adelante y en todos los años que vienen
como por el mismo motivo under google
pero incluyendo por supuesto también la
gran bernal hacer y guita ya varios
ciclistas que están irrumpiendo ahorita
y que están llevando el ciclismo a otro
nivel pero no sé si sí desde el contexto
que nos preventa eslovenia en este
momento es
el de un país que es bastante pequeño un
país muy pequeñito que tiene apenas 2
millones de habitantes no sé si se puede
comparar con el fútbol con uruguay es un
país muy pequeñito de 3 millones y saca
miles de futbolistas hoy eslovenia está
en ese en ese momento de su historia
está sacando varios ciclistas porque la
parálisis que tienen los terrenos y es
un país que aunque no se había visto
antes como se ve ahora es un país que
lleva al ciclismo y sus penas es muy
parecido a colombia además limitan y
está con italia con las dolomitas
entonces tiene montaña tiene donde
entrenar a sus a sus corredores tiene
como hacerlos crecer como formarlos en
el diario 'as' hablamos con compremos
roble antes del tour y él nos contaba
que hace unos años atrás no se veía esto
no se veía que eslovenia tuviera como un
proceso de formación para sus ciclistas
pero unos años atrás comenzó ya con ese
proceso de formación y taddei ponga char
es el resultado de este proceso que
lleva a este país y es
tiene una historia parecida a la de
daniel martínez porque quería ser
futbolista y luego por su hermano ya se
se metió de lleno el ciclismo porque lo
vio correr y luego quiso tener su propia
bicicleta y corrió con su escuela luego
corrió con el equipo de su región luego
fue campeón nacional de ciclocross y
bueno más o menos
estas otras modalidades del ciclismo
como el 5 ciclocross como el ciclo
montañismo en el que estuvo llegan
también luego son muy apetecidos estos
ciclistas en la ruta y eso fue lo que le
pasó a ata de y poca charla entonces
luego en el 2017 llega el
profesionalismo y hoy lo vemos campeón
del tour de francia tres años después lo
más granado fue campeón del tour del
avenir fue campeón de algarve fue
campeón del tour de california que le
ganó a cerillo hijita
y fue tercero en la vuelta españa y
ahora van a lo vemos llevando ya la
camiseta amarilla de tour de france
viento tienda después preguntemos a
nuestro analista lionel puse y qué opina
del estilo del flamante campeón
lionel él ha dicho si algún día me ven
que no atacó es porque no tengo fuerzas
esto ha mencionado para ganar y para los
optimistas pues dicen que es alguien que
tiene una constancia un deseo de
superación pero también hay pesimista el
lyon el que dicen que este alocado
estilo también puede jugarle en contra
en algunas competencias que o bien es al
respecto
yo creo que sí que por quedaréis poca
charm marco este tour de francia y yo
mucho que ver porque fue muy
espectacular en cada subida en cada
montaña estaba ahí peleando atacando eso
tiene que ver con su estilo con su
espíritu creo pero también con la
configuración de este tour de francia
que se presentó para él con una una
pérdida de tiempo lo lo mencionaba muy
bien
juana en su introducción que en la en la
etapa 7 ponga chat que al de un minuto y
20 sobre el lote de los otros favoritos
como primos aerobic por ejemplo de ahí
no tiene otra opción que ataca de ser
ofensivo porque tenía este retraso de
minuto y 20 segundos que podría aparecer
podría aparecer mucho en ciclismo y al
final es ganar el por un minuto entonces
este minuto 20 fue clave yo creo
la estrategia de poca char en este
sector de francia porque porque de a
partir de ahí lo único que busco es
recuperar este tiempo que había perdido
en una etapa plana por lo a causa de los
famosos abanicos que son provocados por
el viento que hay mucho en europa y en
esas etapas que son más más planas el
día siguiente ya poca chad recuperó la
mitad de lo que había perdido 40
segundos como porque atacó porque
llegaban los pirineos y él atacó y los
otros favoritos los dejaron no sabemos
bien si lo tomaron en serio o no o si
sino podrían seguirlo o si pensaron
bueno el chico el niño éste tiene ve un
minuto 20 y entonces lo dejamos
ok porque no representa un peligro
inmediato en la general y de ahí yo creo
que se equivocaron todos sus rivales el
primero de ellos que es primos oro gris
porque después siempre poca chava en
todas las etapas de montaña
no tiempo recuperó ese tiempo excepto en
la etapa 17 cuando miguel ángel lópez
gana la etapa ponga char piel de 30
segundos sobre lópez 17 sobre oro gris
pero si no en todas las otras etapas
tales fogasa recuperó tiempo y llegó con
más con apenas un minuto sobre sobrero
gris en esa contra general de ayer que
todo el mundo pensaba que era favorable
para primos oro bridge vimos
en tal exponga char increíble porque me
dio dos minutos ahora gris y también
ganó con un minuto 20 sobre todo new
moore que es uno de los mejores sino el
mejor en la crono en el mundo y entonces
yo creo que este espíritu de ataque lo
tiene en él en su forma de ver en el
ciclismo que él no le gusta para nada
quedarse en las ruedas y esperar y hacia
el cálculo él quiere atacar es muy
ofensivo muy espectacular como les decía
tatiana también pero yo creo que la
configuración del tour le le le
favoreció en esto en desarrollar esta
estrategia de yo no tengo que nada que
pelear porque ya he perdido un minuto 20
entonces lo único que tengo que hacer es
atacar y recuperar el tiempo perdido y
yo creo que esos dos elementos explican
también la forma de decorar de tareas
fue gastar y lo que logró en este tour
de francia
para poner en contexto a nuestra
audiencia sobre cómo fue estaba como
cuál es el resultado de todas esas
gestas de las que estamos hablando de
esta época vamos a repasar la
clasificación general de este tour de
francia 2020 donde vemos efectivamente
ese triunfo de la época chart
con 59 segundos de ventaja sobre primos
droga y tercero richie por todo el
mérito también para el ciclista
australiano a la décima fue la vencida
para llegar al podio a 330 ya richi por
a partir de ahí mikel landa cuarto
quinto en ring más muy meritorio esa
posición de los ciclistas españoles en
el caso de enric más sobre todo viniendo
de menos a más sexto miguel ángel lópez
del que hablaremos más adelante con el
rendimiento de los latinoamericanos
séptimo tom dumont land que finalmente
entró en una muy buena posición en el
top 310 octavo rigoberto urán 9º adam
bien ya que llegaba decían para ganar
solamente etapa se metió en el top 10 y
muy buena posición también de damiano
caruso cam a 14 minutos décimo el
corredor italiano del bar en mclaren ahí
como bien estamos identificando pues
eslovenia en lo más alto protagonismo
total juan de pocas ar y del rock de
principio a fin para mucho
un desenlace entre ellos que queda
plasmado también lo identificasen la
historia para cerrar este tema crees que
estamos ante el nacimiento de una era
eslovena que se impondrá en el ciclismo
estamos ante el nacimiento de estrellas
de eslovenia que seguramente como
adelantaba tatiana van a impulsar que
más ciclistas lleguen a que más personas
en eslovenia se enamoren de este deporte
tan bonito si es un aero no no lo sé
porque yo creo que estamos en un momento
del ciclismo en donde va a ser muy
difícil que volvamos a ver a un
multicampeón como lo fue el ultimo
christopher froome o en la época de
indurain de inof y demás porque el
ciclismo está siendo hoy en día muy
competitivo además de ponchar hay otro
chico que se llama rincón en el que
mencionaba también la tienda en bernal
va querer revancha de líneas en general
va querer revancha y va a tener
seguramente un muy buen equipo para el
próximo año estamos ante el nacimiento
de una estrella que lo va a tener muy
difícil al igual que la otra generación
que viene para marcar historia y para
dejar una huella en este deporte que ha
cambiado mucho en estos últimos años he
leído artículos de los tres invitados
del día de hoy en sus respectivos medios
voy contigo tatiana por qué
antes tanto juegan como lionel aquí en
el canal que este tour de france podría
ser un partido eslovenia contra colombia
pero el tour parecía que este
enfrentamiento inédito entre los
ciclistas de ambas naciones quedaría a
deber desde tu perspectiva colombia
sólo fue un país el que cumplió las
expectativas
no no creo creo que creo que colombia
cumplió un gran papel también en el tipo
creo que colombia también se mostró
ganamos dos etapas
tuvimos dos corredores en el top 10
claramente no fue el resultado que
buscamos porque teníamos al ganador del
tour y seguramente todos queríamos que
fuera su segundo tour para navegar
bernal pero bueno pasaron muchas cosas
como le decía a leonel la carrera se dio
para que las cosas en formas que yo si
logran o pasaron así y bueno lo que pasó
con ella en su enfermedad del dolor en
su espalda la caída de nairo que además
de ser una caída bastante dolorosa fue
dentro de una mata de ortiga en un tour
de francia que bueno no sé de cierta ha
pasado antes en algún en algún tour este
tipo de situaciones
y bueno estuvimos también con miguel
ángel lópez hasta la penúltima etapa con
la opción de podio pero incluso miguel
ángel lópez fue el único que pudo vencer
en algún momento tanto a cachar como a
primos rowling en la etapa del cordel a
los que ganó el colombiano y bueno
finalmente terminó también en el top 10
en la última etapa rigoberto urán hizo
un top 10 en la en la contrarreloj fue
fue el mejor colombiano en la etapa
también estuvo en el top 10 de la
clasificación general la etapa que
ganamos con daniel martín d
y bueno yo realmente neutral como ese
como el mundial eslovenia colombiano no
no lo vi de esa forma había igual más
rivales a los que también había que
ponerle bastante cuidado como los
españoles como los franceses que también
estaban ahí que también tenían escuadras
muy fuertes
y bueno creo que no que no no lo vi como
en esa pelea por supuesto eslovenia fue
el gran ganador del tour de francia con
depp ocasión también con todo lo que
hizo primos robles durante el tour
teniendo la mayoría de días la camiseta
amarilla entonces no sé si vamos a tener
una hegemonía de eslovenia en los años
que vienen no lo sé probablemente sí
probablemente van a estar ahí siempre
peleando por los puestos de influencia
por los mejores lugares pero el ciclismo
está cambiando bastante el ciclismo hay
cazatalentos en todo el mundo buscando
nuevas promesas buscando ciclistas que
se parezcan a apoyar que se parezcan a
'gran que sean mejores y el ciclismo
estaba corriendo muy rápido entonces no
sé si tengamos una hegemonía eslovena
muy bien tatiana pues como ya nos está
adentrando en el tema de los latinos
vamos a preguntarle a lionel si
coincides con esta percepción que nos
identifica tatiana sobre el balance de
los colombianos que en general puede ser
positivo si lo resume sea solo lópez
gran cara paz y martínez como los
latinoamericanos sobresaliente
quitarías a 1 lionel aumentaría a otro
te escuchamos
yo creo que hay que saber de donde
hacemos la comparación para asia el
balance de colombia y de américa latina
de dónde vienen
llegamos de un tour 2019 el año pasado
que fue histórico con la victoria de
gand hernán y entonces después de esto
obviamente estábamos llenos de esperanza
para él con todo el continente niños no
solamente para colombia pero también
para ecuador con richard carpas que
estaba disputando su primer tour de
francia entonces la esperanza era
obviamente otro título o un pollo para
para colombia es lo que se esperaba no
fue así
fue entonces se puede considerar que si
hay una parte de decepción por el hecho
que colombia venía con cinco corredores
seis corredores que podían estar dentro
del top10 por ejemplo si consideramos
que ganan bernand nairo quintana a
rigoberto urán miguel ángel lópez daniel
martínez
sergio allí está eran capaces de entrar
en este top 10 pero era muy ambicioso y
veníamos llegamos al tour de francia sin
tantas informaciones sobre el nivel de
cada uno había solamente hubo solamente
un mes de carrera antes del inicio del
tour entonces esta temporada tan atípica
a causa del cob y 19 eran e hizo que era
muy difícil saber lo que podía pasar en
este tour de francia
entonces si estoy de acuerdo con tatiana
que no está no está tan mal de ver a
miguel ángel lópez al terminal sexto de
estar peleando durante mucho tiempo en
la general para el pollo de ver a
rigoberto urán que es octavo de un tour
de francia' menos de un año después de
su caída a que fue gravísima el año
pasado en septiembre del año pasado en
la vuelta a españa pasó yo heriberto
gran paso 33 semanas en una cama en un
hospital y estaba pensando a retirarse
quizás a abandonar el ciclismo
y de verlo ahí en el 'top ten' si es
buena noticia y al final
es pues eso es positivo las dos etapas
de ganarás por miguel ángel lópez y por
daniel martínez es también balance
positivo
richard cara paz que no ganó su la etapa
pero terminó y igual que con el ganador
desde que era de su equipo pasaron los
dos juntos la meta y entonces es casi
como si había ganado una etapa del tour
de francia aritz alcalá paz por esta
parte el balance así si es positivo por
otro otra parte si hay decepción por
parte de gun bernal que tuvo que
retirarse porque tenía sí dolores de
espalda no podía seguir y su equipo
seguramente le le pidió abandonar porque
ganan quería parece que quería seguir
hasta parís como lo hizo nairo quintana
que a pesar de dolores mondo vídeos por
las redes sociales mostrando todo todo
todo lo que tenía en el cuerpo de marcas
después desde sus
entonces nairo quintana termina es su
peor resultado resultado en un tour pero
termina yo creo que también es una forma
de victoria para el de terminar este
tour con tanto dolor tanto sufrimiento
hay que llegar hasta parís y entonces
hay positivo al negativo digamos al
balance si se hubiera podido esperar más
un pollo un top 5 de tener como el año
pasado tres corredores colombianos en el
top 10 no fue así pero al final el
balance no está tan negativo lo que
cambia es el hecho que el año pasado
egan bernal fue campeón del tour de
francia entonces ahora estamos esperando
cada año que un latino un colombiano
gana el tour como nos decía a tatiana el
ciclismo es un deporte muy duro y hay un
nivel altísimo en muchos países entonces
siempre hay que relativizar también de
meter matices en esas primeras
interpretaciones que hacemos al final de
un tour de francia
vamos antes de la clasificación general
del tour de francia vamos a ver ahora la
clasificación el top 10 de los
latinoamericanos que terminaron esta
participación en el tour de francia'
2020 tuvimos dos abandonos el de ca'n
bernal el de sergio y key está entre los
mejores latinos el mejor del colombiano
miguel ángel lópez superman que terminó
sexto como lo comentábamos enrico octavo
richard carapaz fue decimotercero
primera vez que un ecuatoriano participa
en un tour de francia' ricerca la paz
que tuvo con un estuvo con un equipo que
tuvo muchísimos problemas muy meritorias
actitud en las últimas etapas para
conseguir esa victoria que le dio algo
de toxina yo 17 se van chaves 23 en el
felipe martínez en la posición número 28
harold tejada del astaná joven promesa
del ciclismo colombiano también 45
winner anacona 66 en la posición 77 está
andrey amador el chico que degusten el
tour de francia con el equipo y neos
haciendo muy bien su labor como siempre
haciendo el gregario que todos quieren y
el del último colombia el último
latinoamericano que tenemos en esa
clasificación es de ayer quintana el
hermano de nairo al que él defiende y
dice que no está en este tour solamente
porque sea su hermano sino porque hace
una labor muy
en la carrera rápidamente juan llegan es
la gran decepción ya no se identificaban
como estábamos de contentos aquí hace un
año con el especial que también
realizamos entonces del campeón
colombiano y ahora pues nos menciona
leones la vara estaba muy alta el ghanés
decepción en tanto que como campeón no
pudo defender su título en tanto a
rendimiento que le se le puede pedir a
un joven que ganó el primer día de
francia para latinoamérica yo creo
intuyo aquí a la cuestión de irán fue de
formación de preparación es algo que
intuyo en lo que pudo haber llegado que
lo pudo haber llevado hay que obligar a
actitud de francia pero como decía antes
este muchacho va a querer revancha el
próximo año y breaks force y el ine os
van a querer revancha ya se van a tener
a adam jets dicen también que van a
tener a richi por van a tener de nuevo
seguramente un mega equipo del otro año
para competir con el que este año ha
sido el todopoderoso yo misma que se
quedó sin el ansiado premio
hablemos precisamente de del equipo
jumbo con tatiana tatiana tú crees que
es pues por supuesto una gran decepción
el dominio que tuvo por gran parte del
tour de francia hace que el altísimo
nivel exigido pues no se le pueda pedir
más
cuál es tu opinión del equipo
si yo sí creo que es una decepción lo
que pasó con el jumbo isma en el tour de
francia y es muy paradójico no porque
era el equipo dominante era un equipo
que veíamos con el tren más poderoso de
todos los equipos incluso que líneas por
primera vez en muchos años un equipo
estaba derrotando a ese tren o estaba
haciendo superior que líneas tuvo tres
victorias en el tour de francia tenía un
líder que parecía bastante sólido que
era primos rowling que se vio muy pocas
veces mal si yo muy pocas veces mal él
no dio tantas ventajas durante todo el
tour creo que incluso las últimas las
dos las dos únicas veces que se ve que
se vio mal y que se dio fue cuando
perdió contra miguel ángel lo que son el
a los y en la penúltima etapa en donde
definitivamente se dio el tour a su
compatriota tarde y poca charla
y a pesar de haber un equipo tan
contundente si se puede decir así
durante todas las etapas de todas formas
fue un equipo conservador un equipo que
no arriesgó
más allá un equipo que no lanzó a su
líder por esas ganas de protegerlos y se
puede decir así y detenerlo como en esa
cápsula de cristal rodeado de grandes
gregarios amando como lo estuvo no no lo
dejó arriesgar no lo dejó hacer un
ataque no fue no pensó en de pronto
tener un poquito más de diferencia para
llegar a la última etapa con un corredor
que claramente el jumbo sabía pues ya le
había ganado al rock en la en la
contrarreloj ctel
el campeonato dueña que sabía que podía
quitarles el título y pues finalmente
eso fue lo que pasó no no vimos un
equipo entre contundentes hay una
paradoja muy rara del ciclismo que nos
dio este tour de francia' 2020 que fue
el equipo más poderoso del equipo que
siempre iba adelante el equipo que
siempre jalaba del pelotón
el equipo que nunca permitirá que otros
hicieran un trabajo diferente para poder
sacar alguna ventaja con respecto a
ellos pero que al final no pudieron pues
mantener esta ventaja que tú que tenían
sobre sobreponga char y terminaron
perdiendo el tour de francia
de esta manera tan dolorosa es que lo
decía antes de lionel y yo creo que lo
define perfectamente lee o eddy merckx
que decía el jumbo visual llegó a la
penúltima etapa del tour dejando al niño
como excelente como ya lo que dijo él
dejando al niño 57 segundos y el jumbo
dejó con mucha vida aprovecharlo
deseadas antes lío
si es que yo creo que se se confiarán
mucho en el rumbo abismo por el hecho
que todo el mundo decía no es que son
increíbles que nunca hemos visto esto
son más fuertes que el team sky ineos
que dominó el ciclismo durante 10 años y
entonces yo creo que ellos mismos se
pensaron muy fuerte lo que sí eran pero
que yo creo que que no tomaron en serio
el peligro que representaba a poca chad
y digo esto porque en la actitud que
tuvieron al frente de época chad yo creo
que no se dieron cuenta que ponga charts
y era capaz de rivalizar con a primos
oro gris en la crono porque porque
supuestamente oro gris era más fuerte
que ponga chalé en la crono es todo todo
el mundo pensaba eso excepto que extrae
como les decía tachan a que en el
campeonato nacional de eslovenia de la
crono ponga charkh ganó a finales de
julio ya ganó el título delante de
primos oro gris pero solamente por nueve
segundos en 15 kilómetros lo que parecía
muy muy cortico muy justo y yo creo que
el jumbo si se equivoca
en su estrategia porque pensaba que ya
el trabajo estaba hecho de llegar a esta
penúltima etapa de contrajeron con un
minuto más o menos de ventaja para
primos grupo euro glitch sobre pared
foca chat hemos visto que no que al
final se equivocaron y yo creo que el
golpe es muy duro para ellos porque
hicieron se parece que hicieron todo
bien durante tres semanas excepto un día
y entonces me imagino que para ellos
es lo vimos ayer sí se han visto la
etapa
las caras de de tan simulada the band
art de que son también del jumbo bismack
que estaban mirando la pantalla y mira
entendiendo lo que estaba tan tensando
que no solamente estaban teniendo el
tour pero también estaban perdiendo la
etapa que tome una iba normalmente a
ganar porque es también uno de los
mejores del mundo en la crono y entonces
creo que este momento de allí al de de
esta etapa de esos minutos o se dan
cuenta que están perdiendo diga entre
comillas todo creo que fue muy duro para
ellos y que de esto van a analizarlo
para volver el año que viene aún más
fuerte y para ver cómo hacer contra un
niño como como tarek tipo cachar bien
lionel pues tatiana un rol y con un gran
equipo ante un poco hallar un corredor
que algunos dicen compitió casi sin
equipo y que por cierto a esta hora ya
tiene 22 años
en eslovenia y es lunes
él nació un 21 de septiembre del 98
felicidades para el flamante campeón
tatiana los equipos está perdiendo
importancia en este nuevo ciclismo los
equipos son más vulnerables que nunca
qué opinas
no no no no lo creo así no lo creo así
por ejemplo en el caso de poca char
se ha dicho con mucha insistencia que no
tenía equipo lo que pasa es que bueno lo
mismo pasó con iron
cuando no estaba en equipo
y me parece que no que no es así lo que
hay hay cosas en la carrera que están
escondidas y que no podemos ver pero que
el equipo está ahí encima de sus campos
está encima de sus líderes y eso creo
que eso fue lo que pasó con vogue a ser
bueno cuando tenía aro cuando tenía todo
formó lo pero cuando se fueron ellos
tenía grandes corredores al suelo a su
lado por ejemplo estaba david de la cruz
tenía la gent se tenía también a
christoph estaba también su compatriota
jean paul and que lo acompañaron que
estuvieron con él e incluso se metieron
en fugas para luego regresar y darle una
mano estar con él entonces creo que no
lo que pasa es que con lo que pasó con
el jumbo
se nos viene a la mente que tal vez el
trabajo de equipo no sirvió para reglas
pero si robbie llover ha tenido un gran
día pues en este momento en el lacón en
la crono si hubiera tener un gran día en
la crono seguramente en este momento
estaríamos hablando maravillas del jumbo
y diciendo que el jumbo lo hizo todo
perfecto porque es que realmente lo hizo
así y no podemos tampoco
como decía lee o echar a un lado el
trabajo que hicieron panaderos que
hicieron secure que hizo el mismo tom de
mul and quiso robert gesink el mismo
tony martin que estuvo siempre también
ahí entonces creo que el trabajo del
equipo
nunca se tiene que subestimar sea un
corredor no puede ganar un tour de
francia sin equipo lo mismo pasó con
nylon decían que la arquilla no pero na
yo tenía a dos hombres de su entera
confianza winner anacona y
muy bien tatiana muchas gracias te tengo
que interrumpir porque nos quedan 50
segunditos y si quisiera que nuestro
periodista deportivo nos dé un cierre
antes de agradecerle a todos con que
concluye juan ganó el esfuerzo ganó en
los intentos detalle por ganar
sonríen los organizadores del tour de
francia que ven que un equipo no puede
dominar esta carrera y para los latinos
de la conclusión de que hay que
prepararse más en la contrarreloj pues
muchísimas gracias juan pupiales que
poco tiempo para tanto que analizar y
con estos especialistas como juegan como
tatiana rodríguez a quien también
agradezco periodistas del diario as
colombia y a lionel para seguir nuestro
analista en france24 especializado en
ciclismo y por supuesto muchas gracias a
ustedes por su compañía ya lo sabe vea
más mucho más en france 24
[Música]